all right so look I can't wait to hear
the new album uh the EP well it's not an
ep the six-pack it's out uh anything
going on with the icy I know you got
gear you'd be doing collabs like what
else merch just so you got the merch
game is is stupid it's nice cute little
like I'm just everything will get bigger
as I grow but this is just like a re a
reintroduction so the merch is like like
a four piece yo your nails are long
mm-hmm they're pretty cool I only get
the long tips does that make anything
difficult in life like calling somebody
or wiping your ass no I'm used to it
it's like an extension of my body so you
have to like do the wrap though right
right when you wipe you have to wrap
around like your hand
you can't just like
with nails like that can you demonstrate
what that looks like okay so if I had
nails like you I would assume that I
would have to take the toilet paper and
I would wrap my hand so then you can
mm-hmm but what happens if you wrap it
too tight
I don't know you might have a shitty
hand ew have you ever had a shitty hair
definitely
that's all of you
at some point in time speak for yourself
everybody in life has had a rough a
rough goal once or twice you had that
single single plot toilet paper that you
know
is in my it might bust through me you
know yeah anyway sweetie is here
appreciate you coming through
go listen to the new music
I'm gonna say just go and press play on
the [ __ ] Song let's see track three
right yeah yeah [ __ ] there you go and
then uh what What's the first one first
one don't say that my goodness
that was a very aggressive record mm-hmm
yeah I like that that was for like my
woman out there yeah
yeah
well don't say nothing
go listen
there it is you got to start getting
these ndas signed you know what I was
thinking that but that's like
like look I appreciate the date to Olive
Garden or wherever someone takes you
whatever I do like Olive Garden of
course you do because Alfredo because
you're a real one listen you told me how
you eat your McDonald's
I totally believe that you like Olive
Garden because Olive Garden's crazy it
is so good with that being said here's a
contract
if this goes any further I'd like to
know that this stays between you and I
okay I'll have you you can send it out
for me and then you could sue them yeah
I could be your lawyer just hire me okay
I don't have a law degree or anything
but I can figure it out you know I think
they'd be scared of you
yeah maybe yeah there it is sweetie
buyer